trace your lineage oh yeah  my lineage goes back to  if you all the way down to the civil war  robert e lee no way you're related  yeah dude did you originate any of his  world views  yeah i did oh no  like the confederate flag i believe in  it i love it  i believe in the 13 colonies is that  what it is i think it's like that  something yeah state rights yeah state  rights i believe in trickle-down  economics  i believe i do i believe in separation  between uh  nitrogen state between races oh yeah  yeah yeah that's a cool thing yeah yeah  there's my grand grand great grandpa did  he go by bobby yeah yeah yeah bobby lee  and if there was stand-up comedy back  then he would have killed it right yeah  he would have been the owen benjamin of  he would have been the own vengeance of  that time